yeah welcome to this video playing Grand
Master see at enough I think this is the
name from Uzbekistan a queen's gambit
yeah I'm okay I always played this
Bishop f4 line a long time actually
before it became more popular damn it's
fairly solid choice he played now with
b6 which is not so common but it's a um
guides am perfectly playable line with
gtx e5 I take a keep it simple approach
not going for an isolated pawn but try
to play for a slight advantage in a
symmetrical position okay and the
question is are probably just queen here
Adam sorry had to stop the recording for
two seconds because I had a really heavy
sneeze here sorry about that you did yet
I felt that there was coming so I could
stop the recording okay so he managed to
to play 65 but I'm not sure that this is
such a great thing wow it's giving me
some nice ideas night f5 okay
yeah this looks excellent for what
I've got two bishops I've got the defile
our rock the one-armed even before mmmm
yeah before midnight my play 96 yeah
just hooked you on keep it simple okay
if he goes rock the eighth what's my
response i can i can play net hmm
hmm
I'd like to use this pinion he cannot
take and I'm threatening to just take
here take a form I'm not sure how he
prevents that I mean prevent damage to
his structure maybe you can or maybe he
could have played show basics this is
over now of course the same opportunity
and now I'm able to play 95 next and
damage the structure or his or maybe he
won't sacrifice this was the idea
exchanging the bishops and then your 95
ok yeah no I can also take with the pawn
maybe this is even better no book takes
rook takes must be better really the
look is on in half opened file
this is just just excellent I'm Queen
Queen to h4 probably em check what to f5
what's up also tasty
I want to make sure that I don't get
surprised on the back rank so 95 mm yeah
ah video looks like there should be some
technical solution to this I don't see
it yet but there really should be
Rock t6 I take Quincy eight kingi seven
at night h 5 i'm not sure that it
doesn't seem to win curiously enough
maybe this one controlling g7 also
controlling g7 now threatening to take
and greets the eighth mate and if he
takes pawn takes I get a passed pawn and
I have this attack on f6 also I've got
Queen g47 as a possible threat yeah this
looks very very dangerous and very very
dangerous probably a very modest way to
put it I don't see a moose
but no more freedom probably needs to
take I if it takes I can I know Queen g4
is got 96 but I'm taking I can just
recap them this is strong enough
black4 fits on time yeah he it's not I
don't know unfair behavior or something
he just he simply didn't find a move yum
Knight d4 as minus 4 I mean + 44 white
um I don't I really don't believe me
five is good it's a bit tricky here he
probably needs to play a five here if I
have to to just prevent before why does
a bit more comfortable because of those
weaknesses but what can you do after
this it gets it gets really tricky do
you want a now Bishop different light is
a rock t6 is also strong admittedly but
this is also good yeah the computer
gives rock d 6 cm is even stronger like
a human just give this check and this
also came
hmm yeah i think it was quite okay but i
played him a fiver cell is really the
problem and maybe around here there's
some way to improve as well a six i
don't know i don't like this too much
this position for black it's a bit
one-sided white has no real risk here
and um it's always a bit better yeah
thanks for watching